good morning Hank it's Wednesday one of
the symptoms of signing madness is
terrible fashion sense it's question
Wednesday the day that I answer real
questions from real nerdfighters let's
get right to it
novel onsens asks books or Irie ders I
don't really care how you read I care
whether you read Pico asks can you solve
a Rubik's Cube
yeah but only in the give a million
monkeys a million typewriters for a
million years and eventually one of them
will write Hamlet way social Hazzard
asks do you have a cover for The Fault
in Our Stars yet yes
heckling rabbits asks describe a fight
between you and a laser armed porcupine
all right I probably started with like a
right cross
wait there's a cover for The Fault in
Our Stars yes yes yes yes yes as of two
minutes ago my publisher Joule oh I am
dizzy Julie Strauss Gable said that I
could share with you the cover of The
Fault in Our Stars I hope you like it as
much as I do da da there's the cover for
the Fault in Our Stars this cover was
designed by Rodrigo Corral my favorite
book designer in the world he designed
the covers for the brief wondrous life
of Oscar Wow and super sad true love
story in the glass castle and the
marriage plot I'm really grateful to him
for thinking enough of The Fault in Our
Stars to want to design the cover and
I'm just in love with it and I hope you
guys like it too also a funny thing
happened my publisher penguin was so
excited about all the cool covers that
were designed by fans for The Fault in
Our Stars that they have decided to let
nerdfighteria designed the new cover of
an abundance of katherines there's a
link in the doobly-doo to abundance of
covers com where you can find out how to
submit and stuff but basically it's
going to be like when everybody designed
covers for The Fault in Our Stars only
one of them will become the actual cover
of the book like maybe forever so please
submit cover seriously because the
future of an abundance of katherines
depends upon it the serie asks what's in
your pockets pizza of course what else
would I put in my pockets helpful
details asks I used to love pizza but
I've grown to hate it is there something
wrong with me helpful details I'm going
to tell you a story once upon a time I
stopped liking pizza and you know why
because I had a diseased gall bladder
and I needed abdominal surgery listen
I'm not a doctor but if you stop liking
pizza is there something wrong with you
yes
herma Jane asks what is your opinion on
the Oxford comma and the controversies
surrounding it I mean like I think
clarity and written language is valuable
but debating the Oxford comma is one of
those things that reminds me that we're
all going to die and that our lives are
composed of like a finite set of moments
that we choose how to spend and I can
help but think that if we turn the
massive parallel processing power of our
brains away from debating the oxford
comment toward like curing malaria or
writing really good Arrested
it's slash fiction we might come out
ahead as a species Claudette asks are
you really gonna sign the entire first
printing of the Fulton oh yes some lost
girl asks recently I met a fellow
nerdfighter through my pizza shirt in my
archaeology class but he hasn't been in
class for five weeks help me find him
name was boy from unknown location why
aren't you going to archaeology classes
if I don't have enough to worry about
now I have to be concerned that you're
gonna fail archaeology I already feel
under pressure asked will there be such
a thing as a heckler fish and unified
copy of The Fault in Our Stars yes but
only one awesome try asks who the eff is
Hank Hank may be the largest island in
the Tuscan Archipelago but Hank wasn't
big enough for Napoleon Hank wasn't big
enough for Napoleon our words that have
never been spoken before in that order
with proper asks what do you believe
brevity is the soul of great question
Tuesday questions I'm gonna do a
question Tuesday next week as well so
nerdfighters leave your questions and
comments Hank I will see you on Friday